he's Chris Sims pro football talk
co-host with Mike Florio former NFL
quarterback first time in the man cave
not bad digs what yeah big-time
improvement damn I mean this is pretty
special I mean the basketball court
tip-top great murals out there it's a
little cleaner in here it's not as best
about you guys anymore it's a lot better
it's an upgrade here we have a football
field out there yep
I'll play quarterback okay sure and
because you'll play wide receiver where
did Chris rank on the best quarterbacks
we've had in studio well we've had Joe
Montana in studio Brees in studio below
him I would say I'm towards the bottom
of the list no matter who you had in the
studio it's mclovin I think he was 71
right behind Blake bortles all right
please next year at the Superbowl set it
up again I want to throw balls as hard
as I can and make love it okay you can
do that next freak oh maybe we'll do
that yeah I will always take that I want
to abuse him yes I go back to the Giants
drafting Daniel Jones and I thought of
your dad believe it or not people made
the comparison of Dave Brown in the
Supplemental Draft with the Giants out
of nowhere and we you know the Giants
got all this got this guy Dave Brown
he's really talented that's like I go
back to your dad who came out of
Morehead State and nobody knew who your
dad was yeah and the reaction was not
kind to your dad when he was drafted by
the Giants but it turned out well I'm
curious if your dad had a chance to talk
to Daniel Jones
yeah what would he say I think he would
tell him don't worry about the the media
noise the public who cares he'd probably
say a swear word in there and go I mean
what the hell do they know anyway how do
you avoid it Chris yes New York it's
social media they didn't have social
media when your dad play you're right
you're not going to avoid it no matter
what even you know even staying off of
social media you're always going to have
a friend or your mother or an aunt who's
gonna go huh did you see what they said
about you today you know that always
happened even to me
back in the day before social media so
yes you're gonna see that but at the
same time I mean are you gonna hear
those things you you know there's a way
to avoid it at least to where it doesn't
consume
your day to me I still think it's crazy
that some of these guys are on a social
media as much as they are and the react
the way they are to to people who don't
know really what the hell they're
talking about anyways and they get you
know a little you know hot over it
altogether but you know had the giant
seemed to like these type of
quarterbacks Daniel Jones
Eli Manning my father I think Hostetler
Kerry Collins right we have this way
about them where it's just it's always
the same guy no matter what
interceptions same face touchdowns same
face and I do think that's a formula the
Giants believe in and I think it does
work in the New York area why does the
GM Dave gentlemen keep talking right
yeah just let let Daniel Jones
play we're gonna find out if he can play
not by your words not by a baker gave
you a bagel and said hey great draft
pick right you got to just go out and
play just trust your evaluation who
cares what people like me or you say
about the pic you know they love the guy
that's where it hey again I did not
think he was a first-round quarterback
I'll say that flat out now do I think
the criticism about the pic is a little
over the top right now and on the player
certainly but this is my New York this
is New York and that's why it's it's
been criticized yeah so much but why
don't you why don't you think Daniel
Jones was the first round town well for
me when you talk about a first-round
talent and especially a top 10
quarterback pick I want a guy that's got
some physically elite traits right
something about him where I go whoa and
that's that's pretty special right there
what an athlete or you know what a great
arm what a great ability to throw the
ball with people around him in the
pocket and he can change the way he
throws it or throws off his back foot a
guy that can carry the team when maybe
the team isn't playing its best or going
through a rough streak with injuries all
those things that's where I looked at
Daniel Jones and just went I don't think
he's that type of talent he's not the
type of guy where he's gonna make a few
throws every game we're gonna go whoa
that was unbelievable no I think he's
more of a guy that if you put a system
around him and he's got a few good
players around him he can do some good
things and be surgical with some of his
accuracy throws underneath and his
decision-making and all that but I just
didn't see that top end talent I guess
that I'd like to see it at the number
six pick who do you think is a Pro
Bowler first Hoskins lock or Daniel
Jones
Hoskins
or Daniel Jones yes it's gonna be very
dependent on who gets in first out of
that it's a really good question there
I'm I'm gonna go with Drew lock here
even though I don't really have an
answer their definitive reason I don't
think any of these guys are gonna go in
and like the world up even in year one
or a year to what feels like Haskins
might play before the other two I would
think so
I mean Haskins is in a situation where I
think he's gonna step on the field the
first day of practice and he's gonna be
next to a Colt McCoy in a case Makena a
Case Keenum and people the team's gonna
look at him ago whoa he's big whoa the
ball comes out of his hand a little
different than the rest of these guys
and yes I would think he's in the
position to start earlier certainly I I
guess I just go with Drew Locke cuz I'm
a little biased there he was my second
favorite quarterback in the draft I
think he's the one that's capable of
doing special things and making some of
the special throws and moments that I
was just describing of what you would
like to see with the first-round
quarterback or a top ten pick I had a
scout tell me that they loved drew Locke
yeah but something's missing because he
went in the second round right but what
what am I missing here well I think the
this happens with all quarterbacks and I
think this is a big issue with
evaluating cortex we put all the team
struggles and issues on the quarterback
always so if drew Locke came out two
years ago when he led college football
with touchdown passes and he was I had a
better offense and coach and system
around him I think there's no doubt he's
a first round pick he's a top twenty
pick I mean that string it's stupid it
happens all the time is not hot right
now it's like two of going back you know
to were coming out next year right you
know Haskins didn't go back to Ohio
State he knew I threw for fifty
touchdown I'm hot now let's go right
let's ride this if you had it if you
looked at two and looked at Kyler yeah
who's who has the potential to be a
better pro quarterback
I think it's Kyler I do yeah I think I
like to I'm not sold on to of being the
number one pick yet I mean if you ask me
who's the number one pick a quarterback
next year off of just TV scouting and
things I saw a cross crossover watching
film knew I would say it's the kid up in
an organ
yeah Herbert would give me you know he
would be the lead whoreson but he went
back he went back to which I know I was
saying at the time when he made the
decision I just went gosh you know you
know again I'm all for kids
getting their education and and enjoying
the college experience but mean you only
get a certain amount of years and
and lifeline in the NFL but I just want
it like with the quarterback thing like
you said I would just want to finish
that thought because it is stupid how
much it goes into every year oh you know
oh the guy it's always the guy on the
good team with good stats oh he's one of
the top quarterbacks like Jake froms
have been thrown in that conversation at
a Georgia I don't think Jake from is
that kind of quarterback and he's not in
a level of twoa or Herbert but because
he's on the good team that's go we go oh
he might be a first-round quarterback
let me just tell you that does not
matter Patrick mahomes was five and
seven his last year at Texas Tech it's a
team sport we got to stop putting the
quarterback on the pedestal in this
country where it's oh it's the
quarterback he's the only guy doing
anything out there John Elway was three
and eight as last year at Stanford it's
about the team around you and I think a
lot of times we're NFL people miss out
on their evaluations is they take too
many of those things into account where
they go well the team one he's a winner
oh okay great he's a winner Tim Tebow
was a winner in college he did great
things I know that but just because he
won at Florida with like 10 other Pro
Bowls around him doesn't mean he is a
you know bona fide NFL starting
quarterback he's Chris Simms Pro
Football Talk live co-hosts NBC Sports
Network with Mike Florio of course
former NFL quarterback whose strategy I
don't like giving grades after the draft
yeah okay because it's to me how do i
grade somebody I don't even know I
haven't seen you even in a uniform I
gotta wait three years to give you a
great yeah whose strategy did you like
the most in the draft well I I think
Pittsburgh made the boldest move of the
draft for a position than they
desperately needed and that was outside
their character of doing that making
trades they don't usually do that type
of stuff so that was a bold move for
truly what they had to find the replace
they had to it's been a really it's a
missing spot on their football team and
shazier was a special football player
but I think when I think about the draft
there's a few teams that I think are
playing chess why everybody else is
playing checkers the New England
Patriots always their strategy of
accumulating not always for the top end
talent but for the next guys down to
build for depth all those things they
get value picks I look at Chris Ballard
with the cultivation and go he's special
John Schneider with the Seattle Seahawks
I love what Seattle did with the pics
that they got from Frank Clarke exactly
I I think they were sneaky great I agree
I think Seattle would be one of those
teams I would put in and go they won the
draft in a lot of ways I mean some of
those picks in the second round were
special players that I think will you
know become something down the road like
Arizona's draft - I do - they addressed
a lot of issues exactly Arizona had a
good free agency period I think quietly
Steve Times had a very good offseason
you know who else am I missing -
dolphins getting Josh Rosen okay I like
that move - you get a second-round pick
basically late second round pick to go
oh this guy could be our French sheep
he's cheap as hell and you got a guy of
basically a one-year trial period and
they have all these assets that they've
acquired as far as draft picks for next
year's draft with Robert Quinn Cameron
Wake and all of those things to wear now
okay let's try it out Josh Rosen I
expect him to be the starter down there
in Miami and if it works out they're
gonna be able to use those assets and
next year's draft for everything other
than the quarterback so I really thought
that was a good move by by that group
down there yeah I was trying to think I
don't know if Jared Stidham is is
considered the heir apparent because the
Patriots have drafted quarterbacks
before but here you are at Toms AIDS now
yes right is he and I had a scout tell
me I give him a first-round grade that I
think he's really talented we got caught
up in how bad his team was and the
previous year he was great and we got
caught up this year in right right and
he got into some bad habits he was he
was trying not to make mistakes uh-huh
and but the Patriots probably got a
first-round Talent at quarterback
I agreed I ranked him ahead of Daniel
Jones if that gives you anything well
but I did I thought he was a really
talented quarterback and again that was
one of the names I was gonna bring up
about the conversation we had really
here we were going to put the team
struggles all on one guy Stidham does
have some has big-time potential out
there really really he was every bit are
more talented than Jimmy Garoppolo
coming out of the draft he's got a bit
of a really big arm it's sneaky strong
he's very athletic can do all the things
we talked about you know again throw
from different angles really reminded me
of like a Tony Romo
type of guy really the way he played the
game but again there's another guy where
his team fell apart the offense stunk he
had the worst pass protection on any of
the quarterbacks I watched and yeah so
then he and then when you're in the SEC
and you're the the the lesser team on
the field on a weekly basis you tend to
like a drew Lok take a few chances
because you know if you don't your
team's not gonna win the football game
and it can get thrown back in your face
with the scouting Department where they
go wall he threw a few risky
interceptions there well yeah he was
trying to win the game so if he could
have checked it down all day long and
been charlie checked down but they would
have lost by 28 points is that what you
wanted no so I do think the Patriots
found uh you know diamond-in-the-rough
shocker
the Patriots found a good player were
you charlie checked out not at all
I was Bobby bombs away how often did you
change a play uh occasionally did you
get yelled at well Gruden we'd never
just called one play in the huddle so it
was always gonna be two or three I have
you an example well okay we might go all
right here's here's the huddle call hey
West right slot Zee counter orbit 72 Zee
bingo you split we're gonna can it with
58 Lexus Apple 314 hammer dummy snap
count on one ready break okay that would
be the play call right there and then I
would walk up to the line of scrimmage
and say rocker or Tyson to remind
everybody was a dummy snap count because
rocker the pitcher from Atlanta was a
jumper right he was a dummy and enticing
and that was our code word for her being
like dummy snap count don't jump I be
like on Tyson Tyson Tyson Tyson so
though a lot of code versus and Sean
rocker was the dummy yes he was the
dummy code why was Tyson I don't know
why I just said listen to whatever
Gruden said and I said okay sure at that
time I think Tyson had just bit you know
just off the fresh biting of the year
every vendor Holyfield and those type of
things but lots of code words and yeah
you get up to the line of scrimmage and
blue d5 blue d5 set hut hut hut okay
okay I know we don't like this play
check check check
and then it goes to the 58 Lexus and if
I said Apple it would have gone to 314
hammer so that's that's life as a
quarterback in the NFL it's one thing to
be the quarterback and you have to
understand this and be the conductor
right there are other players who may
not be as bright as the quarterback who
were you know going right way what's the
snap count they may not know the damn
plane you're exactly right that's why
you hear New England always you know
drafting and free agent signings the
guys that are very smart cuz their
systems are complex they don't need that
they don't they don't need Tom walking
the line of scrimmage going go you've
run the post route here and then if
they've run this coverage you run that
you know but you're always gonna have a
few guys like that in the huddle
especially the young guys where you know
there would be certain day I hate you
ask me I'll tell you just don't ask me
when we're already lined up in the
middle of the snap count ask me as we're
breaking the huddle
I'm not wrap guys turn around say what's
the snap count oh definitely I mean they
had the center I can remember we're
playing Baltimore and John Wade in 2006
where it's hot as hell and it's the
Baltimore Ravens and Ray Lewis and we're
all stressed out because they're big and
bad and physical and we we have a dummy
snap count on one and I remember him
turning around in the middle of it like
wait what's it on and I was like dummy
one dummy so you're telling the defense
yeah right right and Ray was so smart he
was all over it yes but he's right
talking to you Ray is always talking
when he was on the football field one of
the greatest experiences I ever had in
my short NFL career of playing the first
snap of the game you know we were all
white because it was the first game of
the year it's hot in Tampa Florida and
Baltimore didn't give a crap they were
all black dancing around the ball
singing it's football time because it
was the first game of the year and we're
not at a commercial break and I'm
looking out there going man we're real
nervous in this huddle and there Terrell
Suggs and him and everybody they were
real loose and ready to kick our butt
and they kicked our butt that was good
defense that was a really good deep and
if they had a couple oh man they did
yeah yeah and and brains to go along
with brawn I think that's what jumped
out to me I mean ray he had a few plays
that day where he called out the run you
know as I'm going said Hut and he's
gonna do the running right there and I'm
I go there you go Michael Pittman how
fun
the huddle we'll take a break it's a
trigger meet Friday we we do have meat
out there but we were gonna go out let's
throw some passes okay
we are the first quarterback that we've
had here oh I get to a I get to christen
the field well I don't know what that
means
I don't know hopefully you throw a
completion I hope so too all right and
then you can throw it as hard as you
wanted make love it I mean you can just
bring it sold you know I I go back to
Aaron Rodgers when Aaron Rodgers threw a
ball so hard that I thought if McLovin
's heart got in the way that ball he
would have stopped his heart hey Aaron
Rodgers ball the first time I saw it in
person I went whoa that's a different it
spins so hard and comes at you in such a
hurry that's why he's special
well Elway had that too how weighted to
Brett Favre yeah Marino and his prime
those guys yeah they could just
absolutely sling it we'll take a break
here we'll come back with Chris Sims and
we'll close up shop here on this meet
Friday we're back after this on the Dan
Patrick show I'm catching it for Chris
what do you want to do you want to run
now do you go you got your hold on you
have a down jacket on now you need to
put a body vest on there we go to the 10
and just come straight in that would be
the bingo part of basic in right yeah Oh
horrible not a quarterback surrounded
was it rounded rounded right he's won
key to a seven-step so I quit you mom
because it's a high up all right when
you
nobody knows a seven-step drop in it
then you get there they will get subdued
you're right it's that common outside
this way and then over that way I can't
really see very okay what could go wrong
what could go wrong I see some speed how
about a buttonhook love it and Chris
will bring some juice yeah it bring some
noise okay gonna go right there gonna
stay there all right here we go I'll do
a little I'll do a little Aaron Rodgers
here yeah I give the whole he's Chris
Sims kind enough to join us on loan from
the NBC Sports Network and we're
throwing the football around out in the
in the Fieldhouse there
McLovin looks like a receiver didn't act
like a receiver now I let you down now
Chris was throwing up with some juice
there he's bringing some cheese yeah I
got a few I was a little off target but
it's alright I got it there do they care
how strong your arm is now like the like
people care about my doctors like nobody
cares about my arm anymore did I care
right but do we care like how important
is arm strength in the NFL I again I
think it you know when people go well oh
you won't some people say that - you
only like quarterbacks with strong arms
they go yeah well I like receivers that
are fast and defensive tackles that are
strong so yes I do
you know it's not the only thing in the
world but I do think there's a reason
you know some of the great quarterbacks
of all time had really strong arms we
mentioned a few before Alvin
Montana did not you're right certainly
he was a great passer that's why they
made my dad and I would say he's a
little bit different that way where it's
about rhythm and timing and anticipation
and drew brees is like that as well it's
not always about the power throws but
arm strength isn't important you saw
Patrick mahomes this year they can call
plays in their offense that other teams
can't call because they can go well our
guy can hit that and throw it right on
the money
all the time and so it gives the
offensive play caller and play designer
the ability to call different things for
their offense that yes guys with their
teams with other quarterbacks with less
than average arms or average arms
they're not going to be able to dream of
calling some of those plays why did
everybody miss John Patrick mahomes my
big thing is it was Texas Tech so
everybody thought oh this is just one of
those system they throw the ball every
time and then they looked at the five
and seven record and they thought well
how good can he really be I don't I was
one of those and and you can go back and
look at what I used to say I'm bleacher
report at the time I i will pat myself
on the back with this one and they and
even Patrick mahomes has given me credit
for this is I said the first time I
watched this film I can remember
watching the film and I called my dad
when I got done and I went oh my gosh
dad this Patrick my Holmes you gotta
check him out this guy is like
unbelievable I don't know if I've seen
anybody throw the ball like him here and
I mean in the recent history or anything
like that and I went on bleacher report
our podcast and said it and I got text
messages from NFL people like right away
you're crazy mahomes isn't that good
what are you looking at blah blah blah
and then few weeks went by and everybody
was you know his stock was rising but
what happens a lot of times is you'll
have people in the media who have mock
drafts and then they're surprised when
somebody moves up but the NFL teams get
their hands on you they're not gonna let
you know what they're going to do no and
that's when I got word that I should
have Patrick asked out said you should
have Patrick mahomes on prior to the
draft he's moving up right and we had
him on and then of course he moved up he
moved a month before the draft we had
him on because I was told he's the guy
who's moving up yeah him and Watson
right we're moving up yeah and it turned
out to be true it did well it goes back
to what we talked about a little earlier
in the
show is just elite traits right and
those two guys had things where I well
there's just not many people in the
history of the sport that can do some of
the things they do that's this is
special like Watson's ability not only
to make big throws but dance around the
pocket and make big throws in big
moments that was special then mahomes
you know there was enough special every
game I watched where I just went whoa I
mean that is like that's Aaron Rodgers
type throws right there and then people
would knock him down and go all what
about the TCU game and there was a few
games like this where I wanted to go
okay that's great but you know let's go
back and watch some of those games
together tell me who's open or who he's
supposed to throw to in some of these
moments and I never saw I came in I
think they played Oklahoma State and I
came in on Monday and I said I don't
know if he can play right but I've never
seen somebody look like and they were in
the backyard taking control and just you
know having fun and that's what we saw
Oh fritzy would you learn today by the
way if the Sixers win it all you're okay
with giving McLovin a day off to attend
the parade and fill the glove and what
did you learn Chris Sam is pretty decent
jump shot O'Connor what did you learn
people not interested in Chris Simms arm
strength anymore yeah what did you learn
mr. Bisky loves you Dan what did you
learn today Chris what this is that it
pays to be Dan Patrick and have a studio
like this that's what I learned I mean
this is gosh can't hide money Dan for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app